streets sliced open by shrapnel scorched
Vehicles bombed out buildings the
Ukrainian Army retook the southern city
of kirstan from Russia but it Bears the
wounds of battle as does the entire
country in a conflict that's reshaping
both Europe and the world and leaving
its mark on the year 2022. nobody really
expected anything like that to happen in
Europe it's been what 75 years or so
since the last war an ipsos poll done
for Global News found more than 70
percent of Canadians believe the war in
Ukraine is the biggest international
news story of the year just saw the uh
the president of of Ukraine and
Washington
um you know it's it's clearly you know
front page news and people are paying
attention this defense expert predicts
they will have to keep paying attention
because this will be a protracted War
Russia knows it would probably be
playing the long game so the question is
uh is NATO going to remain as cohesive
as they sounded in 2022. while Canadians
were concerned about conflict abroad
they were also focused on economic
uncertainty at home and the rising cost
of living
40 percent of Canadians consider Rising
interest rates and inflation the second
biggest International Story the war in
Ukraine is helping drive up energy costs
while the pandemic keeps disrupting
Supply chains all these factors have
fueled record food prices these macro
events became very micro meaning they
hit everybody personally and
individually the freedom Convoy that
took over Ottawa also dominated the
conversation 62 percent of Canadians
consider it the top domestic story
economists believe Financial fear is the
theme of 2022 and what connects all
these headlines I think inflation has
plateaued and what we're going to see
are gradual keyword is gradual slow
declines in inflation the top stories of
2022 that will shape the next year terea
isri Global News
Ottawa